[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález pero sigue
inmerso en un espiral de caos e
ingobernabilidad el presidente ha
modificado su gabinete o se ha visto
obligado a tener que cambiarlo en cuatro
ocasiones en menos de seis meses el
penúltimo grupo de ministros solamente
duró siete días en sus cargos en total
van cerca de 29 ministros que han sido
cambiados así quedó conformado el nuevo
gabinete que presentó el presidente
castillo días atrás veamos
sin su icónico sombrero el presidente de
perú pedro castillo tomó la
juramentación a su nuevo consejo de
ministros- el cuarto en seis meses
incluyó cambios en 6 sectores además de
la presidencia del consejo de ministros
que ahora estará bajo el mando de aníbal
torres jurar por dios y estos santos
evangelios
desempeñar lean y fielmente el cargo de
presidente del consejo de ministros que
os confío si juro
si así lo hiciera es que dios os premio
y si no él y la patria os lo demande
ángel y the phone solo reemplazará en el
cargo de ministro de justicia hernán
condori es el nuevo ministro de salud
castillo retiró a wilber supo del
ministerio del ambiente ya que era uno
de los ministros más cuestionados del
gabinete y designó a modesto montoya en
este consejo ministerial sólo hay tres
mujeres una menos que en el anterior y
dos menos que en el de mirtha vásquez
entre ellas la activista feminista diana
miloslavich stupak quien se pronunció
previo a la ceremonia
demandamos un gobierno que nos
represente y que nos incluya en las
políticas de estado para alcanzar la
igualdad de género y no la
discriminación en el ejercicio de
nuestros derechos
ahora torres tiene 30 días para
solicitar el voto de confianza al
congreso de la república el nombramiento
de este nuevo gabinete se da tras la
renuncia de héctor valer a la
presidencia del consejo de ministros
quien fue presionado por la indignación
del pueblo peruano tras conocer las
acusaciones de violencia doméstica que
pesan sobre el duró tres días en el
cargo
la inesperada llegada al poder de pedro
castillo guardaba una leve esperanza de
devolverle un poco de estabilidad a ese
país suramericano pero las críticas los
escándalos no se han hecho esperar
tampoco recientemente la fiscalía de
perú allanó hace unos días como les digo
con fines de incautación el palacio de
gobierno por el caso de petroperú el
operativo también comprometió 14
inmuebles vinculados en la investigación
por presunto direccionamiento en la
adquisición de biodiesel b100 a cargo de
petroperú que es una empresa estatal se
trata del tercer escándalo que salpica
al presidente que cuenta con inmunidad
tal y como lo indica la constitución de
perú desde la presidencia argumentan que
ellos están cumpliendo con su trabajo y
que el mandatario está intentando
gobernar en un ambiente adverso perú se
muestra entonces ingobernable y de nuevo
el fantasma de una nueva crisis política
comienza a asomarse por diferentes
partes que va a suceder entonces con
este país suramericano la crisis de
gobernabilidad y de inestabilidad en
perú que parece no tener una salida esta
es nuestro tema de debate hoy en france
24 y para analizarlos saludamos a
adriana urrutia ideas politóloga y
presidenta de la asociación civil de
transparencia de perú ella se encuentra
en la ciudad de lima la capital peruana
también desde esta ciudad se conecta
darío pedrag joel es politólogo hace
parte del grupo de análisis político 51
ustedes también los televidentes hacen
parte de este debate pueden participar
con sus preguntas y sus comentarios a
través de las redes sociales en facebook
en instagram y en twitter no pues nos
pueden encontrar como france24 y un bajo
es ella santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 esperamos todos los
comentarios y las preguntas y comienzo
entonces el debate preguntándole adriana
allí en la ciudad de lima la pregunta
básica en lo que se está haciendo las
preguntas que se está haciendo todo el
mundo en este momento pero se convirtió
en un país completamente ingobernable
como llegó a esta instancia que ni el
congreso funciona ni las autoridades
funcionan ni las instituciones y bueno
el presidente le está costando mucho
gobernar y llevar las riendas
y muchísimas gracias por la oportunidad
de estar esta tarde aquí con ustedes
la crisis de el perú no es una crisis de
corto plazo no es una crisis de largo
plazo si queremos ponernos más
estructurales podemos decir que es desde
los años 90 que previene es cierto
viviendo un colapso del sistema de
partidos pero esta crisis se agrava en
realidad es del año 2016 cuando la
fuerza política perdedora no liderada
por keiko fujimori no reconoce los
resultados de las elecciones y luego el
partido de gobierno liderado por el
entonces presidente pedro pablo
kuczynski se ve también envuelto en
escándalos de corrupción no entonces la
confrontación entre ejecutivo y
legislativo ha tenido esa confrontación
entre ejecutivo y legislativo ha tenido
un conjunto de consecuencias que han
venido debilitando diferentes
instituciones que conforman el sistema
democrático en el país
más corto plazo vamos a decir que la
crisis es responsabilidad del liderazgo
de ted hastío y las debilidades que
tienen la organización también que lo
lleva a cargo y la incapacidad de
nuestro presidente de enmendar los
errores que ha sido expuesto y en el
poder darío pedrag lo también allí en la
ciudad de lima la capital de perú su
opinión porque este país es es tan
difícil gobernar lo porque no funcionan
las instituciones el congreso a la
presidencia y las diferentes
instituciones públicas que lo que
suceden y cuál es su opinión
como estaban muchas gracias por la
invitación si como señala adriana creo
que esto es una crisis de largo aliento
en el perú creo que estamos viendo ya
que nuestro retorno de democracia
después del gobierno de fujimori
comienza a entrar en una situación de
precariedad
constante y nos encontramos con que le
sumaría lo que dijo adriana que después
de la vacancia pedro de la salida de
pedro pablo kuczynski y la vacancia a
martín vizcarra se abre una nueva puerta
que nos había abierto hasta el momento
que era la posibilidad de remover a los
presidentes incluso también de la
disolución del congreso entonces
comenzaron a entrar elementos que los
años previos no estaban todavía en juego
que sumados a la baja institucionalidad
la crisis partidaria la informalidad en
nuestra política de nuestra sociedad
abriendo un espacio de ingobernabilidad
que muchas veces termina siendo ya una
constante no siendo algo que caracteriza
nuestro sistema político y que la verdad
por lo menos en el corto plazo no
pareciera que vaya a cambiar
hago la ronda a la inversa continúo con
darío allí en la ciudad de lima para
preguntarle por una pregunta que puede
ser de pronto muy obvia para ustedes
pero para quienes estamos fuera de las
fronteras peruanas nos cuesta un poco
entender por qué no están funcionando
los gabinetes de ministros del gobierno
del castillo porque hay una mala
elección en las personas que lo componen
en los ministros sabemos que hay varios
casos de corrupción casos que salpican a
los a las personas que la elegidos para
su gabinete pero más allá de eso no
logran avanzar en ninguno de los
proyectos ni avanzar en algo básico de
cada una de las carteras quién está
asesorando al presidente para elegir a
estos ministros cómo es ese proceso que
lo que está pasando
bueno creo que el origen de los
problemas de presidente es que me parece
que ni él mismo pensó que iba a poder
ganar la elección no creo que cuando el
postula con perú libre el objetivo
probablemente era superar la valla que
el partido así existiendo meter a algún
congresista pero nunca creo que se hayan
imaginado que iban a obtener la
presidencia y la república entonces a
partir de eso tenemos un presidente y un
entorno del presidente que me parece no
está preparado para asumir las reinas de
un país como el perú que tienen
muchísimos problemas y en este sentido
también se nota una cierta improvisación
no creo que el presidente en el partido
perú y libre cuenta con cuadros
políticos ni técnicos que les permitan
ocupar carteras creo que las relaciones
que tienen son un gran sentido
relaciones que va construyendo
relaciones nuevas relaciones que esas
más del presidente con su región que es
cajamarca y entonces en la elección de
los de los ministros está muy limitado
en a quien puede buscar quien está
dispuesta a aceptar también un impuesto
en el gobierno luego de los escándalos
que tuvieran mencionados santiago
entonces estos son una suma de factores
que llevan a que el presidente no solo
elija mal en muchos casos sino que tenga
que rectificar constantemente
adriana su opinión sobre esta
imposibilidad de hacer funcionar los
gabinetes para conocer la opinión las
dos caras de la moneda delante
a ver en
el año pasado cuando castillo era
candidato a la presidencia se
comprometió y firmó una proclama
ciudadana tenía por título juramento por
la democracia que constaba de 12 puntos
eran los mínimos democráticos que el
ahora presidente se comprometía a
respetarnos a partir de esos compromisos
que firmó la sociedad civil nos hemos
organizado desde la asociación sin
transparencia para constituir una
plataforma que se llama la plataforma
vigilantes con más de 10 organizaciones
la sociedad civil que presentó un primer
reporte en diciembre del año pasado
entre esas alertas y ya se señalaban en
diciembre la principal y una de las
principales la más grave quizás era que
en él
el cargo de presidente castillo no había
sido capaz de nombrar a personas idóneas
en el puesto esto que quiere decir que
tenía ha nombrado a personas que no
conocen los ministerios que non estaban
en el estado de un puesto de liderazgo
que simplemente no conocen las temáticas
y esto es muy grave porque estamos
restándole al estado la capacidad de
retribuirle los derechos a los
ciudadanos en el sentido que le estamos
restando capacidad de liderazgo
capacidad de respuesta y coherente y
dificultamos no la retribución de
cualquier servicio público no en ese
sentido el 300 responsable de esos
nombramientos hemos hecho ya un llamaba
que enmiende esos errores pero parece no
querer recetas
adriana daría ustedes están allí en perú
ve en el día a día de cómo está
avanzando este gobierno liderado por
castillo pero precisamente una de las
críticas es que al presidente le cuesta
liderar
tiene poca capacidad de liderazgo dicen
que es un presidente muy aislado de la
realidad del país al menos así lo
describen algunos analistas allí en perú
y que no está ni conectado con el pueblo
ni tampoco muy conectado con sus
funcionarios qué opinión o qué pero en
percepción tienen ustedes de esa
capacidad de liderazgo y de cómo está
llevando castillo el gobierno
algunas algunos analistas dicen que no
habla ni siquiera con los ministros que
simplemente se alimenta de los reportes
que hacen algunos asesores y que son
acceso a información muy limitada de lo
que sucede en el país en realidad
para dianas esta pregunta pues los dos
en realidad pero comienzo con adrián a
gracias santiago
ahí creo que lo que hay que señalar es
que la lógica de ejercicio del poder de
presidente pedro castillo es una lógica
de patrón hace decir él se reúne con un
conjunto de actores que considera que
representan ciertos intereses y en los
cuales él se debe y por ende los
involucra los vincula se acerca a ellos
en el gobierno y creo que el tipo de
liderazgo que pretende ejercer se basa
en en esa defensa de esos intereses
particulares entonces es el liderazgo
que es débil se superpone a la necesidad
de tener un jefe de estado que lidere el
estado no precisamente y vemos que ahí
tiene mucha dificultad del señor
castillo para sacar adelante es la
palabra de río pero aquí sí varió la
opinión
si estoy de acuerdo complementando diría
que además es un presidente que creo que
desconoce profundamente cómo funciona el
estado cómo funcionan los distintos
sectores cómo es que se suelen afrontar
desde desde el estado los problemas que
tiene el perú y cómo mejorar los
servicios y cómo acercarse más a la
ciudadanía creo que es un presidente que
no no tiene ese bagaje que como él mismo
dijo en la entrevista que dio hace hace
un tiempo está en proceso de aprendizaje
simplemente que lamentablemente hasta
ahora nos vemos muy bien ese aprendizaje
los frutos de ese aprendizaje nos vemos
los mismos errores y vemos que parece
que es todavía un presidente que basa
sus liderazgo en un círculo muy pequeño
muy cercano de personas que mientras
quizás él confía pero que tampoco
pareciera que tuvieran el conocimiento
técnico como para llevar a cabo adelante
las reformas que el propio castillo
propuso durante la campaña y que creo
que la ciudadanía también se está dando
cuenta como reflejan las últimas
encuestas que el presidente pareciera no
tener la capacidad por lo menos hasta el
momento de implementar las cosas el
mismo prometió el presidente propuso
varias reformas a los transportes
públicos al sistema de pensiones a la
constitución
prometió también diferentes mejoras en
los sistemas sociales allí en perú y
ninguno de estos proyectos todavía está
en marcha
voy a hacer aquí un poco de balance
quiero pasar al otro lado de la moneda
para ver la perspectiva desde el lado
del gobierno el gobierno y el presidente
castillo ya lo han dicho él mismo lo ha
dicho que no ha tenido no tenía la
formación para gobernar así lo ha dicho
en varias entrevistas a medios
internacionales
y ha dicho que ha tenido que gobernar en
medio de la adversidad que tan adverso
ha sido el entorno político
adriana en contra del presidente ha
tenido apoyo de su partido ha tenido
también distanciamiento con su propio
partido algunos partidos más pequeños se
alían se alejan
como ha sido entonces estos seis meses
políticamente hablando para el
presidente en cuanto a los apoyos dentro
del gobierno porque pues finalmente lo
que no pensaría es que el gobierno
unificado trataría de hacer lo mejor
posible por sacar el país adelante
así es al diario creo caso es un claro
reflejo de la dinámica partidaria en el
perú en el último tiempo los partidos
políticos actúan como condiciones e
intereses como dicen volver a nuestro
mauricio zabaleta no condiciones de
independientes que tienen un conjunto de
intereses
y buscan llegar al poder en función de
esos intereses no tienen precisamente
como tú bien lo señalas una dinámica
partidaria que lo que busca es defender
una agenda y gestionar el poder para
hacer realidad esa agenda no en ese
sentido en lo que ocurrió con perú libre
es el desmantelamiento
digamos de las alianzas o un digamos un
conjunto de vínculos que son muy
precarios no entre el jefe de estado y
el partido político perú libre que está
liderado por la emir serrón que es una
figura que ciertamente con su liderazgo
entra en conflicto con la figura del
presidente y debilita esta figura
también cuando en ese sentido la bancada
de perú libre no hacía una banca sólida
además también ha perdido a los más
representantes son en el marco de un
contexto que tampoco actúa de un
congreso perdón que no ha actuado con
responsabilidad y tiene parte de
responsabilidad en esta crisis no porque
en vez de proponer reformas o de buscar
salir adelante de la extensión política
en la que nos encontramos ha promulgado
leyes que lo que buscan es reforzar su
poder político frente al ejecutivo no en
este sentido también son responsables
del agravamiento progresivo de esta
crisis claro aquí lo que la crítica no
solamente al presidente sino que lo
estaba en general tiene muchos problemas
en su funcionamiento hay que decir que
el presidente castillo ha gobernado en
medio de la pandemia de kobe 19 la
vacunación entre los peruanos ha
marchado a buen ritmo pese a las
dificultades que hubo al inicio para
obtener vacunas y el gran precio que ha
tenido que pagar no sólo perú sino la
región de américa latina en cuanto a
personas que han fallecido por como el
19 pero es un país que ha logrado hacer
frente a la situación y también ha
logrado algo que vale la pena destacar y
es mantener un poco estable la moneda
peruana frente al dólar en términos
económicos eso es algo que rescatan
algunos algunos analistas de la gestión
que ha logrado hacer de mandatario en
medio de este
clima de adversidad que se le ha
presentado en el terreno local y también
en el terreno internacional con la
crisis del cobi 19 darío este cuarto
gabinete que llega ahora a liderar en
las diferentes carteras ministeriales lo
ve a usted como un gabinete de
supervivencia que va a estar ahí es
simplemente para mantener como pueda
castillo en el poder o todavía él pese a
la poca popularidad y aceptación que
tiene logrará mantenerse tranquilo en el
poder o esto es simplemente de
supervivencia
no yo creo que en mi opinión latina es
exactamente la palabra me parece que es
una viñeta de supervivencia me parece
que es un gabinete con el cual el
presidente y su entorno han buscado casi
voto a voto lograr los 44 votos que
necesitan para evitar una vacancia y en
ese sentido también creo que hay una
responsabilidad de la oposición porque
si uno esperaba que el presidente
castillo
decida o opte por por un gabinete de
consenso un gabinete que busca captar a
la mayor cantidad fuerzas políticas que
estén dispuestas a gobernar un gabinete
que busquen más bien llegar a ciento
ciertos acuerdos mínimos
creo que eso era muy complicado cuando
el fantasma de la vacancia detrás porque
porque lo que el presidente le asegura
sobrevivir es la bancada de perú libre
principalmente y para tener el respaldo
de la banca pero libre él tenía que
tener una buena relación me parece
completa mil se rompe y en ese sentido
del optado por conformar un gabinete en
el cual pero libre es decir vladimir
cerrón en particular tenga una mayor
presencia y eso le ha permitido creo por
lo menos en el corto plazo un poco de
aire de que no va a ser vacado por lo
menos en el pre técnico en el tiempo más
corto sin embargo ahí sí creo que
a la oposición mientras siga redoblando
su apuesta por la vacancia va a acercar
aún más al presidente castillo al ala
más radical de perú libre a los 44 votos
que necesita y ahí no va a dejar de lado
cualquier posibilidad de consenso aunque
no le aseguran ningún tipo de
permanencia dejemos sobre la mesa el
tema de la vacancia ya lo vamos a
analizar eso es un posible escenario en
el futuro quiero analizar con adriana
esto que estamos hablando de ese
gabinete de supervivencia que costo
político puede tener este tipo de
gabinetes para la política del país ya
sabemos que el costo ha sido altísimo
para el presidente y para su partido
pero para el sistema político peruano
para la democracia para la estabilidad
del país tener este gabinete que
simplemente lo que hace es sobrellevar
la situación como pueda pero no avanza
en ningún tipo de política
hacia adelante
y estamos de acuerdo y este es un punto
de no retorno en términos de
fortalecimiento de la democracia y del
sistema democrático en el país cómo
vamos a salir de un punto en donde 7 de
cada 10 peruanos no confía en las
instituciones representativas más de la
mitad de la población está dispuesta a
cambiar la democracia por algún tipo de
régimen autoritario en situación de
crisis como esta entonces debieran ser
los representantes políticos quienes nos
ratifican en la decisión no cotidiano de
aceptar la democracia como régimen y sin
embargo aquí lo que vemos es que pugnan
por defender estos intereses
particulares que dejan de lado nuestra
fe en la posibilidad de la
representación y la pertinencia de la
representación nosotros estamos aquí en
un punto de no retorno que le va a
costar muy caro y anterior
adriana continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa hablemos del tema de
la vacancia lo vamos a discutir también
con dario hay posibilidades de
enfrentarse a ese escenario una nueva
votación en el congreso donde el
presidente pueda estar
exponiéndose a tener que dejar el cargo
dependiendo de lo que se está
presentando allí políticamente le hago
la pregunta usted ya me dirá sí sí sí
eso podría suceder ese escenario no
efectivamente la figura de la vacancia
es una figura que ha sido nombrada por
algunos representantes políticos como
mecanismo esa guía al activismo pero la
vacancia decreciente y nosotros como
peruanos ya hemos estado ahí antes no es
un mecanismo que nos permita salir de la
crisis política no una ruta podría ser
la evaluación de una reforma y política
integral que respete a la constitución
para encontrar ciertos parámetros que
permitan más bien dar salida a la
situación de entrampamiento en la que
nos encontramos y ahí deben ser las
autoridades políticas quienes tomen esas
decisiones no soy la figura de vacancia
presidencial debilita la figura de
presidente de la institución
presidencial que es parte del componente
del sistema democrático pero también un
complejiza la figura de elecciones
porque la alumna del parlamento
convocar elecciones presidenciales sin
convocar a las elecciones congresales y
esto no está planteado de esa manera en
la constitución y cualquier reforma que
se plantee debe respetar los parámetros
constitucionales por supuesto siempre
bajo el marco de la ley darío eso en
cuanto a
los intereses políticos las
discrepancias políticas que hay allí
entre los partidos y los intereses que
hay pero que hay del pueblo peruano que
el pueblo peruano se canse de esta
situación de esta falta de liderazgo y
comience a salir a las calles a exigir
un cambio a exigir la vacancia al
presidente oa exigir simplemente que
convoquen a elecciones o dependiendo de
cómo la constitución peruana lo permita
pero que sea el pueblo el que haga un
llamado a un cambio urgente eso es
viable eso lo ve usted también ese
malestar entre los peruanos es tangible
a ver creo que el malestar existe sin
duda creo que la última encuesta de
ipsos refleja ese malestar
no sé si es mayoritario el interés de
que se vaya solo castillo me parece que
no me parece que en todo caso el pedido
es que se vayan todos pero como dice
adriana esto es algo que no
necesariamente favorece a las
instituciones y demás creo yo que no
daría solución a los problemas en los
cuales nos enfrentamos no simplemente
nos sumergiría en un mayor una mayor
inestabilidad una mayor incertidumbre
que puede terminar generando más
problemas
de acá a que se generen marchas
movilizaciones no estoy seguro por lo
menos en el corto plazo no estoy seguro
de que se haya aprendido ya digamos la
llama de la de las movilizaciones que
sea el descontento tal como para que
salgan a las calles de forma masiva a la
ciudadanía y exijan la salida de todos
pero sin duda es una posibilidad no creo
que especialmente si el parlamento opta
por lograr la vacancia del presidente y
opta por quedarse ellos y solo hacer
elecciones presidenciales me parece que
es así es un escenario en el cual la
ciudadanía podría manifestar su
descontento de forma significativa
y representativamente hay alguien que
pueda sacar a perú de este tipo de
situaciones que se le está presentando
darío hay alguna figura política que
esté sobresaliendo aprovechando esta
coyuntura que está viviendo el país
mira me parece que no en mi opinión me
parece que no porque la legitimidad que
tiene el presidente en niveles son sus
niveles muy similares a los que tienen
los líderes opositores
entonces la salida la salida de que se
vayan todos básicamente no nos deja con
nuevos actores ni con nuevas reglas de
juego como para que uno espere que el
resultado en caso hay una nueva elección
sea muy distinto al que nos hemos
enfrentado hace poco más de seis meses
nosotros si tenemos los mismos actores
que eran que han muy rechazados en las
elecciones las elecciones del presidente
castillo en la primera vuelta obtuvo
menos del 20 por ciento de los votos
válidos
las opositora keiko fujimori también
entonces la ciudadanía no se ve
representada por estas personas y en el
corto plazo no parecieran que haber
opciones muy distintas quizás aparezca
alguien en el que siempre es posible en
este país que aparezca el nuevo pero no
apareciera si no cambiamos las reglas
del juego que las cosas vayan a ser muy
distintas
adriana sé que es difícil la pregunta
que voy a hacer es muy compleja creo que
tiene muchas aristas para pero como
puede entonces pero salir de esta
espiral de crisis de falta de liderazgo
de gobernabilidad de un parlamento con
un 70 por ciento de aprobación de
desaprobación por parte de los
ciudadanos y un país en donde la gente
ya no confía en la política tradicional
pero tal parece que este experimento de
una política diferente tampoco les está
funcionando que piensa usted
para el fortalecimiento de la democracia
tendremos que estar todos involucrados
en el primer responsable de la crisis es
el presidente pedro castillo y él debe
sacarnos de ella en primer lugar no debe
enmendar los errores en nombramiento
como ministro de salud cuya falta de
idoneidad en el cargo nos va a costar
probablemente avances en algunos
esfuerzos que venían siendo reconocidos
como el único esfuerzo considerable de
este gobierno usted es el presidente
debe ratificarse en esas decisiones y
debe de buscar en cierto dejar de
aprender para gobernar
y aliarse con personas que le permitan
plantear una agenda que cumpla con esas
reformas que como señala su santiago se
había comprometido al inicio de su
mandato y como resultado de una campaña
en el segundo lugar desde el parlamento
se debe tomar con responsabilidad el
ejercicio de la función representativa y
se deben buscar salidas constitucionales
a la crisis sin afectar las
instituciones democráticas y buscando
conducir en el marco de la constitución
algunas reformas que nos permitan
fortalecer el sistema y que nos permitan
evitar una crisis mayúscula y sobre todo
una mayor zozobra en el país y
finalmente creo que la sociedad civil y
desde la sociedad civil organizada
tenemos que permanecer vigilantes y
ejercer una ciudadanía activa que le
haga recordar a los representantes
políticos cuáles son las agendas de los
ciudadanos peruanos y los cuales deben
ser la prioridad en este momento tiene
encanta me quedo con esta frase adriana
dejar de aprender para gobernar es tal
vez una frase que no solamente se aplica
el caso de perú sino también a otros
países de américa latina de donde ha
habido ciertos episodios de falta de
liderazgo y gobernabilidad darío su
opinión sobre este tema para el cierre
del programa que puede hacer perú que
escenarios son posibles que pueden
empezar a cambiar allí en su país para
destrabar esta crisis política y empezar
a ver un poco la salida al final del
túnel sí sin duda como dice adriana creo
que el principal responsable y quien
debe asumir el líder al ser presidente
de la república creo que él tiene que
asumir que ha cometido errores y
enmendar esos errores
creo que tiene que hacer cambios en su
cartera encima del ministerio de salud
pero también creo que debe buscar
construir ciertos consensos no solo con
la oposición sino con la ciudadanía con
esos mínimos
creo además que desde la oposición
también se debería estamos hablando del
deber ser no creo que deberían dejar del
lado de la vacancia sí bien seguir con
su rol de fiscalización de controlar
desde asegurar que no se haga nada
irregular desde el ejecutivo pero
intentar encontrar puntos en común
mínimo no creo que hay ciertos aspectos
de la reforma política que son
necesarios afrontar creo que no se puede
retroceder lo avanzado por ejemplo en
aspectos como la las médulas reforma
universitaria lo reforme transporte creo
que es muy importante que tanto el
ejecutivo como el legislativo sean
responsables en ese sentido porque en
esos puntos sí a veces tienen acuerdo en
retroceder algunas cosas que no deben
retroceder pues creo que debemos lograr
ciertos acuerdos mínimos desde la
ciudadanía también porque nos
corresponde debe mantenernos vigilantes
y exigir al gobierno y al congreso que
sigan apostando por estas reformas y que
logren acuerdos mínimos nada más que eso
bueno pues solamente el tiempo dirá cuál
va a ser el desenlace de esta crisis
política que está viviendo pero no
solamente con el gobierno del presidente
castillo ya es una crisis que lleva
varios años allí en un espiral de
complicaciones a nivel político y
discrepancias entre ciudadanos congreso
gobierno de turno y envuelve todo
a diferentes aspectos porque también
termina afectando la economía termina
afectando la credibilidad de perú a
nivel internacional y de la credibilidad
de las instituciones por parte de los
ciudadanos
adriana y a darío en la ciudad de lima
en la capital de perú les agradezco por
haber estado con nosotros aquí en el
programa haber compartido con nosotros
sus opiniones y sus puntos de vista en
torno a este tema a ustedes les
agradezco por la sintonía por haber
estado con nosotros y pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios y sus preguntas
relacionadas con este tema a través de
las redes sociales mientras tanto
también los invito a seguir viendo
france24 sigan con nosotros
[Música]